And then use those API's to move, to physically move the
camera.
You're just like, yes, move the camera. And then you wait. And
all of a sudden, it goes, you're like, Oh, like
best part of hacking when you can just get a critical thing.
All right. Hackers, if you're really looking to take the deep
dive this year, I really recommend you check out the
critical thinkers tier in the CTV discord. Okay. This is the
place where we are doing hack alongs AMA is giving you
exclusive content that only the inner circle has access to, to
boost you as a hacker masterclasses, you know, custom
interviews with extended interviews with guests, that
sort of thing. It's a great way to support the pod. And it's a
great way to invest in yourself as a hacker. And it's a tax
write off for sure. So give it a shot. Check it out. CTV. Show
slash discord. We'll help you join us. Thanks.
Hey, what's up y'all. Um, welcome back to critical thinking
today. We have one of our dear friends. And in my opinion, uh,
one of the greatest experts from a hardware hacking perspective,
uh, Mr. Matt Brown, uh,
I want to give him a round of applause right here for you.
Exactly. And, uh, in, in, uh, normal fashion as Justin likes to
do, we'll start straight with the bug. So why don't you give
us a cool bug?
All right. Thank you guys for having me on the pod. Uh, it's
good to be back. Uh, yeah. So, uh, this bug I wanted to share
is, uh, is one that I found in, let's just say an industrial, uh,
control system, uh, a little bit more or less, uh, consumer
facing, a business facing kind of a target. And so, uh, this, uh,
piece of hardware that I got sent to, uh, do some bug bounty hunting
on, uh, was, uh, effectively a device that allowed you to remotely
view the controls of this, you know, very large, uh, expensive
industrial control system. And so, uh, there was this protocol, uh, in
it that would, uh, would reach out to the, to the internet from the
device. And so, uh, the first thing I do, uh, on any, any kind of
device that's communicating over the network, I'm an old school, like
network wire shark guy. So I love to, uh, open up wire shark, uh,
monitor all the traffic that's going on, uh, between the device
and the internet. And, uh, I was seeing, uh, some interesting, uh, UDP
data. So a lot of times, uh, maybe in the, in the web hacking
world, you're used to just, uh, you're kind of, you know, standard,
you know, IP, TCP, you know, you're probably got TLS and then on,
and then inside of that TLS session is HTTP. Well, in the IoT world,
you get a lot of like custom, uh, rolled UDP protocols. And so I
was actually seeing some, uh, some clear text data kind of going
through that stream that gave me some intelligence. Uh, let's
just say it gave me some, uh, some information about, uh, this
device and, uh, a session ID. And then I started poking into the
mobile app. So I always like to like to go down multiple avenues, uh,
for these IoT targets. And oftentimes there's some kind of a
mobile app, or maybe a thick client that will interact with the
cloud and, uh, kind of sync data down. And so I started, uh,
digging into the mobile app, did, uh, kind of the standard
unpinning. So I, I, I got free to in there, modified the app
and, uh, got it unpinned so I could see the web traffic from
the, from the mobile app. And I found there was this, let's just
say a, a, a, a incremental, uh, session token that was more or
less being used to, uh, to connect to this remote session to
remotely view this, this piece of industrial, uh, equipment. Right.
And it wasn't exactly a UNIX timestamp. Right. So there was some
part, you know, you know, it was, it was close to that, but it wasn't
exactly a UNIX timestamp. Well, well, it didn't line up with the
exact date. Right. But you could see that it was incrementing at the
level of like a mill, like, like the integer was incrementing at the
millisecond kind of level or the second level. I forget it as well.
Matt, they changed it. Yeah. Yeah. It wasn't, it wasn't the actual
UNIX epoch. They added a few days to it. You know, that's
pretty much encryption in my book, you know? Yeah, yeah, yeah. Well,
yeah. And, and, and especially in the hardware and IOT world, when you
start to dig in some of these devices, the, the security model is like
obscurity, right? It's security through obscurity sometimes. So, um, so
when I had my device, I was able to initiate a session and I was able to
see that session ID of my device. And. What was also interesting is that
the whole fleet kind of operated on the same incremental, like the
server side was handing out the session token. Uh, and so I was able to
just initiate a session on my device and then either go, you know, walk
backwards or forwards from that session ID. And I was able to remotely
connect to other remote sessions, uh, uh, and, and monitor other
people's, uh, industrial control systems. So that is nuts. Like, I
mean, we, we, we've all heard of like incremental ID or not going to
lie. Incremental session token is one that I haven't heard before.
That's nuts. And you didn't even call it. I was a bug there.
Cause obviously it takes man in the middle, but they were also in
plaintext, right? Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. That part was, uh,
kind of wrapped up in, uh, let's just say another finding that I, that I
reported and, and, uh, and, and that, that, that ended up being a dupe.
And yeah, there, there's a whole, there's a whole bunch of, uh, stuff
that happened with the result of this, uh, fine.
Well, I kind of wanted to ask about that. So, I mean, this is a hardware
bug bounty. They sent you the, the, the hardware device, right?
Yes. You start hacking on it. Um, what are the, what are the
bounties like? How do they, how do they compare to web?
Uh, yeah, they, they were significantly better than, uh, their
kind of standard program. So this, this target had, uh, a public program.
And I find this is the case. A lot of times there's like a public program
and then they have a private hardware program. And I would say the bugs were,
uh, about three X, uh, whatever.
The categories of the web of the web was, that's what I'd like to see.
You know, we were talking about this a little bit before the episode,
before we started, you know, recording, but like there, there've been some programs
out there where they're like, throw a hardware device at us and they're like,
you know, it's either like one X, their normal bounties, right?
So just their normal bounties or sometimes even lower.
And I'm like, guys, no, like, I'm not gonna, you don't understand
how much time this takes, you know? Um, so it is good to see a little bit
of a multiple there where you get a premium for that unique skillset.
Oh yeah, now that we're past the first bug, why don't you intro Matt for us?
Okay. All right. All right, guys, you guys know, Matt, we, we did an episode
with Matt in the past, but if you, if you haven't caught that one, Matt Brown is like,
I don't know, man, I'll, I'll tell a little backstory here as well.
Matt lives close to me in the United States and we met up and I was trying to get him a while
back to like join the critical thinking brand because I love his product so much.
His hardware hacking videos are unbelievable. They've been taken off on YouTube left and right.
Um, they are just the kind of technical, you know, quality content that we love here at
critical thinking where you're actually getting down in the weeds of it. Um, talking about the,
the, the details. And, and I, I don't know, I guess as somebody who considers myself like,
you know, intermediate beginner, intermediate in hardware hacking, like the, the stuff is advanced,
where I'm, I'm learning a lot, but it's approachable enough, uh, to help me grow, you know?
Um, so it's really, really good. And that, I mean, that is a very hard, you know, needle to thread
there, in my opinion, like being approachable, but also like clearly, you know, advanced.
Um, so I, I love Matt's, uh, Matt's hardware stuff and yeah, he's, he's been doing some, um,
you know, some work penetration testing off the back of that. And, uh, and yeah, I don't know,
man, I guess I just, we just vibe. So, uh, I love to have you on the podcast to talk about,
um, hardware hacking stuff. And that last episode we did was one of my favorites that we've recorded.
Well, thanks. Yeah. It's good to, good to be on again. Yeah. Yeah. Um, so I, um, you know,
the main vision or goal for this episode, I think that, uh, the reason why I was so excited to have
Matt on is we have just seen since he was on last a huge explosion of humanoid robots, right? You know,
they're not in everybody's home yet, but you see marketing material for them literally everywhere
on every social media platform. People are talking about it. There's like the little creepy one with
like the weird eyes that came out recently. There's already been multiple, like take over
every robot vulnerability found. And I think that there's something from like a security research
perspective that is much more visceral when it comes to a hardware device in your home. You know,
I think Justin on the Halloween episode had an insane hardware related finding where, you know,
a device could be listening to you in your home, but it gets even more real. I mean,
obviously having like an iRobot vacuum, that's like spying on you and going room to room is like
also pretty intense, but a robot that can actually harm you, that actually has the ability to like
physically harm you or steal your things or break your things. If someone were to take over, it feels
real in a way that, um, nothing else does. Right. I don't know. Maybe it's because there's movies like
iRobot or whatever that have, that have come out. But anyways, I want to get mad on. Cause I think that
like just the idea of hacking the robots of the future is like such, um, a crazy and a cool idea.
And, um, and then, you know, there's, there's already a huge discussion to be had around, um,
hardware bug bounty hacking. And then personally, you know, I'm like really interested in AI in general.
And so I wanted to talk to them about like two things. We're gonna get to all these topics, but
the one is, you know, can you, and how would you use AI to assist hardware hacking?
And then kind of the other thing is like, if, if a person was just like getting into bug bounty,
uh, for hardware, because I think that hardware hacking is going to be more resilient to,
you know, the hackbot takeover or whatever. I'm actually more optimistic about this,
but we'll get, we can get into it later. But if someone wanted to get into hardware, um, hacking,
you know, how would they do it? Um, and I know that's a common question for you, Matt. So I'm
excited to hear all those answers. Um, but yeah, let's, let's, let's start with, um, you know,
where you and Justin were already at, like, how do you kind of see the hardware bug bounty scene?
Is it like better than it's ever been? Has it been like kind of declining? Like, how do you,
as it, is it growing? Um, and you know, I'll have there been some that you've seen that have
like already incorporated AI to some of the hardware devices or not? Are you getting asked about that
for your call reach out? Yeah. So the hardware bug bounty scene is, uh, an interesting beast,
I would say. Uh, and, and I think there's some things that are aligned with the general bug bounty
scene in that program selection is really important, right? You guys have experienced this. You,
you know, it's, it's always a risk to invest time into a new program because you don't know
how they operate, if they're going to take your findings seriously, if they're going to shortchange
you or just downgrade severity because they have budget issues or something like that. So I think
there's just more risk in that in the, in the hardware scene, because like you said, there's a lot
of initial time investment that you're going to put into a hardware hacking target. And so, uh, if you
land, if you roll the dice on a bad program, you're going to find out later on down the line,
that, that they're not a good fit, right? So there are, uh, but there, but there are, there are good
hardware bug bounty programs out there. There's not as many public ones is what I've experienced. So
unfortunately, you have to kind of dip your toe in the water, uh, with one of them. And then once,
once you get a couple of findings under your belt, you're going to get those, those private invites,
which is really helpful in the hardware scene because sometimes there are private programs out
there that have a device that you can't even go buy online, right? It, it might be a, a B2B type of a,
a device that you can't just, you can just go on Amazon and buy this thing, right? Um, obviously for
consumer facing devices, you can do that. And if it's a public program, um, but I, I do think that,
uh, there is an advantage, uh, to hardware bug bounty where some of these public programs,
if you get one finding, uh, especially on a specific program, you might instantly get invited
to a private event, a private, uh, program. Uh, that's pretty cool. Whereas, whereas in the web
scene, I think you have to grind a lot more to, to get those invites, like to live hacking events and
things like that. So I've talked to some people, they submitted one bug. It was a good bug. And then
they got invited to an event because it was a hardware target. That's so that's awesome. Have you,
do you have any public programs that you want to shout out for the hardware hacking world that you've had
good experiences with? Yeah. I mean, I mean, Amazon, so, uh, their, their, their program is public.
I mean, they have, they have, yeah. So they have the thing that impresses me about Amazon's program
is that their description of severity is very well defined and there's a cutout for hardware. So they
define the severity very specifically for their hardware targets that matches their threat model.
So you guys have talked about this on the pod before when you're interacting with a program,
you want to figure out what matters to them, right? Uh, but sometimes if you're, if it's,
if you're new to a program and they don't tell you what their threat model is, you just have to guess
and submit bugs. And then you get like, you think it's a high, they come back and they're like,
that's a low, we've got compensating controls. We don't really, that's not in our threat model.
And you have to kind of almost like test the target, uh, to see what their threat model is.
And the thing I appreciate about appreciate about Amazon, and I would encourage anyone who's building
a hardware bug bounty program is to just have like, it's, it's just a simple little paragraph,
right? That they have for, this is severity, this, uh, or this is a critical. These are the kinds of
very hardware specific findings that would fall into that category and then layering down from there in
the other severity categories. So that's so helpful because there's just not like, you get into a
situation where there's, uh, unmet expectations, right? And so, uh, like we said with hardware,
it just takes longer for you to figure out that those expectations aren't aligned if you're going in
blind. So yeah, that's scary, man. That's scary for normal bug bounty hunters, right? But it's worse for
hardware hackers because there's so much upfront investment. It's good to hear that you vouch for
the Amazon program because they have a lot of devices too. I've also had a really good experience
with the Amazon hardware hacking program. Um, so that seems like a good place for people to start
at if they're, uh, if they're looking to kick off. Yeah. Yeah. On that bug bounty metagame point.
Um, I think one thing that's worth stating is that the, the platforms will realize, will like learn that
you're a hardware hacker as well. And in fact, in the platforms, you can go tag that. So a lot of times,
if you go edit your profile and like hacker one or bug crowd or what have you, you can go in there and
set like, oh, I have an expertise or an interest in hardware hacking, please send me hardware hacking
invites. And then I think, like you said, once you submit a couple, the platform program owners,
you know, the, the, the people at hacker one or bug crowd, or yes, we hack or whatever,
we'll see that you have an interest in this and that you can actually find real volumes and then
we'll start giving you those invites. So I think that's a really, really clutch recommendation.
Yeah. I did want to circle back around to one of those rapid fire questions that
Rezo shot at you in the beginning, which was the, um, the AI on hardware devices stuff. Have you run
into any of that? And, uh, you know, do you have any nuance about, uh, threat models or anything that's
different in that world? So I haven't run into any of that in a bug bounty target. I've, I've run into
some of those systems, uh, professionally and private pen tests that I can't, I can't, I can't get into
obviously, but I can't say generally about the IOT and hardware industry. There's some really interesting
things happening. So even before the LLM boom, let's call it, there was a push to get machine learning.
Uh, think especially in security camera context, right? You have your doorbell, you want your doorbell to
identify if a person is coming up to your front door and you want to get a push notification, maybe with
like a thumbnail, right? A clip. And you want it to do the AI to, you know, you don't want just motion
detection. You don't want just like some leaves blow by your door, uh, to trigger this alert. Right.
And so I would say phase one of machine learning on hardware was the, the doorbell, the camera, the,
the, whatever the thing would send all that data back to the cloud and they'd have a data center for
like with servers, with Nvidia GPUs, uh, in it. And they would do all of their, the heavy lift, uh,
on the backend and then they would send the push notification. And what people don't like about that
is it takes time, right? Uh, for if, if somebody's approaching my property, I like seconds matter,
right? Like in, in a kind of physical security context or, uh, or some other contexts like that.
And so phase two has been to bring AI to the edge on the hardware, right? And so now you're seeing
platforms like the Nvidia Jetson that bring, uh, kind of GPU or, or you have Google's like TPU,
tenser, uh, processing units that bring, uh, ML acceleration to hardware on the edge. That's low
power, right? That stuff in the data center, they don't, they don't really care about, uh, you know,
conserving power. Like it's not running on battery in the data center, but you have these devices now
that are running all those algorithms locally. And what I think you're going to see, and I've already
seen some of this is you're starting to see LMS get involved with, uh, devices on the edge. I saw the
other day, this toy for children. Oh, geez. That, that it's like, help, help your kids socialize by
having a talk to this robot. Oh, which is not, you know, I know this isn't a parenting, uh, podcast here,
but I think we could all give, uh, some, uh, advice on why that's not a great idea. Yeah. Geez. Wow.
But in that case, now in that case, it's moving back to the phase one model where I'm sure what
that's doing is it's got some API keys on it and it's, uh, sending your voice input. Maybe it's doing,
you know, voice to text on the device, but then it's shipping that to the backend. But I'm thinking,
how close are we to where they'll want to bring that locally on the device and run kind of like a
local LLM on devices. And then you're going to have, you know, prompt injection on hardware,
uh, things like that, where, where those kinds of bugs, I, I haven't, I haven't seen a bug like that
yet, but I just think that if we look at what happened in the ML space with, with trying to bring
ML to the edge to do like object, object detection, things like that, I think you're going to probably
see that in the LLM space also. Yeah. I, uh, I had this exact desire this morning. I got a Tesla
update to my model Y last night. And when I got in my car today and I've wanted this for a while,
it said like Grok can now control your navigation in your car. So they've exposed and it was like in
beta. And so they've exposed some tool call in, in like Grok on Tesla that, that can now like
control things in the car. And so like, I've been looking for this exact moment to start looking for
bugs in this because before the Grok and the Tesla's was just the chat bot. Like it was just,
and it had no personalization and I still don't think it has any personalization, but anyways,
I couldn't get it to work. Like literally Grok wouldn't respond all morning in my car.
So I'm kind of annoyed because I wanted to test this exact thing, right? It's like, yeah,
you're right. There are going to be prompt injection in physical hardware devices. And, um, and yeah,
I think that toys right now could have a raspberry pie in them that can run small models. There are some like
really small models like Gemma 1B and stuff that could totally have like baby conversation. Like,
you know, it's not going to be good. It's not gonna be able to tell you any legitimately useful
information about the world, but it can say hi. And how are you? And it can imitate, uh, Elsa or
whatever. Right. Our kids are going to start saying, certainly you're right. Oh yeah. You're so right, dad.
Yeah. It's just gonna turn them totally sycophantic or whatever, like these models. Oh my gosh, dude,
that's terrifying. That's freaking terrifying. Yeah. Um, wow. Well, yeah, I definitely think that makes
sense. You know, if you've seen the trend with ML, um, it will probably also hit that with AI. I'm trying to
think about, you know, attack vectors for that. I mean, there could be, um, you know, an MCP server
built into the device where it's triggering tool calls and stuff like that. Um, and, you know, maybe
you're speaking to it and you know, you say, Hey, do this. And it does it. Um, so that, that certainly
seems interesting. Uh, but I think it's just another way to interface with the device in large capacity.
So, um, I think it might, I'm trying to think about like, how, how would I actually convert this into
like, you know, an actual reasonable vulnerability besides business logic. And I'm like, I guess I could
say apostrophe, semi-colon, you know, and it's like, if it's piping into a command line, you know,
you could do it, but I think it'd be pretty challenging to do that verbally.
Yeah. So I put thought into this and I've always thought that you would basically record a payload.
So you would work a lot with your own device. You'd have a recorded payload. And so, and you would
also play it, play it like sub, what's the word where you like humans can't hear it.
Oh yeah. I don't know the word, but anyways, there's a word for that. Like you would, so you would play it
below what humans could play, or you could play it with certain tones that are out of the human range.
So you can still play it loud, but it would be like really high pitch or really low pitch or something.
And you would prerecord it. And so then when you get in the car with someone's Tesla, you would play it
and it would, then it would automatically do that thing. Right.
Oh shit. Yeah. That's crazy.
That's the way you pull it off. Or have you seen this? Matt would probably know way more about this
than me. There's like things like called like directional speakers. No, actually, I think you can
transmit audio to input mics via like infrared too or something. I've seen like you can do it with lasers.
So yes, you go ahead. No, I, you know more about me.
Yeah. Yeah. So Sammy cam car is, his work is what you'd want to look into, uh, YouTube,
Defcon Cox, everything. Uh, so he found that he could use a laser and, uh, you know, send audio
with a laser microphone through a window and activate an Amazon Alexa device, uh, and speak.
So you could record it, translate it into whatever his laser input is, and then shoot it through a window
towards someone's Amazon Alexa device to like trigger a, uh, what's it called? Oh, actually.
Yeah.
I recently heard this is the, I'm not going to mention the company. There was, uh, a vulnerability
that was reported where you could start a call with somebody that, and they would open up the audio.
So you could essentially enable their audio via a prompt. And so if you could put that through this
laser thing through the camera, you could basically turn on a mic at the house. Holy moly dude.
That's crazy. That's the full chain, dude. How do people come up with this shit with the lasers and
like, Oh my gosh, geez. Wow. That's a good question. I don't even understand how audio works to
know how it would go through a laser. Yeah, that, yeah, that's a lot of physics, uh, physics stuff there.
Yeah, for sure. Let's, um, let's, I'm sorry. We, we got a little distracted with the AI, uh, IOT,
um, dreaming here. Let's circle back around. Um, uh, Joseph, did you want to go into some of this,
uh, like attacking how these robots would, you know, how we would go after these robots,
or did you have a different, um, track for that?
Yeah. So I do want to get to Matt Brown's IOT Hackbot and Matt Brown's zero to hero guide,
but yeah, that was actually one of my questions that I don't even think I put it in the doc,
but it's like the main point of the episode, like that I wanted to know personally, it's like
Matt Brown, we've delivered you a unit tree robot or a Boston dynamics robot. Cause honestly,
me and Justin would love to, uh, get one of these in alpha or beta test on. And because it'd be so fun
to have one when they're probably going to be like 50 K when they come out, but yeah, you know, Tesla
drops you a new human robot. What would be like, you know, give us the first eight hours of you
like basically a pen testing this thing, you know, what, what does that look like?
Oh, wow. This is great. Yeah. Yeah. So any device like that, uh, there's, there's going to be a
reconnaissance phase, right? Uh, it's, it's a little bit simpler with consumer facing electronics.
Uh, cause you can, you can get a lot of information off the FCC. Uh, if, if, if, if it transmits
wirelessly and it's sold in the United States, uh, then by law, they have to report certain details
about like the inner workings of the device and post it on the FCC's website. And there's a third
party website that searches that information way better called FCC. I FCC ID.io. And so, uh,
basic reconnaissance, honestly, nowadays I use Grok for all of my hardware recon. I'll like put in like,
Hey, here's, here's the target. If I know anything, any other details about, uh, about the device,
I'll say, Hey, you know, like look into all the sub components that I know about at the time and give
me any, you know, known CVEs, any kind of past research blog posts. And so I just kind of send
Grok out to be like, Hey, deep search, you know, turn, turn on deep search, send it out. Um, and then
I'll let that run while I start opening up the device. And so I'm going to open up the device. I'm going to
gather more, uh, data about what chips I see inside of it. Probably like, you know, add that into the
Grok flow. Um, but then I'm looking, are you using Grok as like your primary AI for this? Cause I, I,
I hear that like, I don't hear that, that very often. I'm mostly hearing people using like Gemini or
Claude. So, so I use Claude for all tool calling stuff, but I, I just use Grok because it doesn't,
it doesn't take up my, my Claude tokens, uh, when I'm doing like light, light internet search recon
stuff. Uh, so like that's literally just in the web browser. Uh, all my other AI like hacking flows
now are, are Claude, Claude based. I think that's smart. I did the same thing, Justin. I don't know
if I've mentioned it much, but like if I have a random question that I expect would be enhanced by
web results and just other users, like the stuff in the past, you know, you used to Google like
something, something, something Reddit, because you wanted like the public opinion about the thing.
Now I use Grok for that because it's going to like be looking at all those tweets that are
kind of relevant. And then it also does a pretty good job of searching online. And it's also really
fast. Um, so I also do that for like, when I want a quick answer about stuff that I want public opinion
about and public documentation about. That's interesting. I'll often use Gemini for that,
but I'll, I'll have to check out Grok and I use Grok a little bit on mobile. Cause it's like
right built right into the X app and I can just be like, you know, but, um,
um, yeah, I, I'll have to give that a go and see how it, how it performs. Um, okay. So swinging back
around to that, you're, you're performing recon the device, you kick off an agent to go do some, uh,
FCC, um, recon, you're opening up the device. Um, and then I guess it just kind of depends on what you
see there. I mean, uh, do you have, do you have thoughts on like how you think that that might be
implemented in the future or are we just going to have to wait and see?
Oh yeah. So for the, for the robotics
tech, um, no, one of those hardware assessments would be so fun because it's going to be a little
more complex, most likely than your average IOT device where there's one processor. It might be a
microcontroller. It might be a CPU, like running Linux or Android, but your average device, there's
like one processor, maybe some, some flash storage, some external flash storage, uh, maybe there's a debug
connector, but in these more complex systems, there's oftentimes, you know, circuitry, there's often
like multiple PCBs. It might be in different parts of the robot. So you might have to like take apart the
head and that's like the camera unit and take apart the body. And that's like the motor control, uh, processor
units. And so, uh, then what the cool thing about those systems where there are multiple, uh, kind of
PCBs or components, uh, they have to talk to each other somehow. So that's where you can use a logic
analyzer to start to read those digital signals. Your, your base is basically a physical, uh, you can
visualize it as wire shark at the physical level. You're physically looking at the electrical signals that
are going back and forth between these different subsystems of a robot like that and trying to see,
you know, how they work, right? Like, like when the CPU wants to send like a message to the arm that
says like, move up, it's going to, uh, send some kind of a digital signal. And so you can play with
those a little bit. Uh, that's not a vulnerability in and of itself because it's like, okay, you need
physical access to the thing. Um, but in any, in any hardware assessment, I'm looking for two large
components and that is debug interfaces. And those vary based on, uh, what your target is, but a debug
interface is something that the developer uses to develop on the target, right? It's a developer tool
that maybe gets them access to log data, maybe get some access to a shell, maybe on a microcontroller
unit, it lets them upload code and, and, and download code. And so seeing if any of those debug interfaces
are enabled is, uh, step. And that's, that's going to be you art, right? J tag, or like, do you often see
something like where you can just hook it up, hook up to it via like USB and like, uh, is that something
you also see or? Yeah, you see that especially on, uh, Android devices. You'll, you'll see USB
interfaces and sometimes they'll be like on the circuit board, but there won't be like a USB header,
uh, you know, soldered up to it. So sometimes, uh, all you, all you have to do is like take a USB cord,
cut it. And then you got the four wires. That's so bad ass dude. And so you've got power grounds and then
you've got your signal plus your plus and minus for your signal. And you just, it's four USB is four
wires and you gotta, you know, you maybe do some in your reconnaissance. You look at the data sheet, you
say, okay, I think this is where I solder onto. And now you've got your USB hooked up again.
I haven't, I haven't ever done any of this with, with USB before, but how, how does that differ from like
you art in this scenario? Cause my, my, my thing, you know, my, you art adapter that I've got sounds
very similar to what you just described there. Yeah. So it is, um, it's similar and it's different.
So USB, I like, like, I think we're all like understand at a, at a high level that USB does
different things. Right. Uh, you know, on my computer, I have a bunch of USB ports, but those
aren't just like giving me shells on, on, on, on my computer. Right. That'd be a pretty bad threat
model for like, to be, to be just like, Oh, I plug in, I get a shell. Um, so there, it could be a, a,
just a hub, right? Where, where you can like, maybe, maybe you can connect in a device and then
the operating system can choose to use that device, uh, kind of like your PC, or it could be an interface
for say ADB. So on Android targets, if, uh, if the, if the, uh, ADB is enabled, then if you get a USB
connection to it, you can then on your PC that you've connected up this USB, this newly populated
USB interface, you can type, you know, ADB devices and it will enumerate over that USB interface. If it,
if it can connect to a device, you can say ADB shell. And then if, again, if it's enabled,
drops you to a shell, uh, yeah. Yeah. So I guess on these, on these, uh, just one, one last thing on
that. And then I'll let you, you take it, Joseph. Um, you know, on these sort of, I guess, more robotic
oriented devices, have you seen a trend one way or the other between these three sort of debug
interfaces, you are J tag or, or USB. So on, on, on robotic devices, there's almost like I mentioned
how there's going to be multiple PCBs. Yeah. There's probably going to be both. So there's probably
going to be, because if you think of, uh, anything that's doing, uh, onboard ML or, or AI, it's going
to most likely be running Linux. The most popular platform I've seen out there is the NVIDIA Jetson
platform. So, uh, NVIDIA makes this embedded GPU that is not as power hungry as their, you know,
as their, uh, kind of data center or, or, or, uh, desktop models, obviously. So that can,
and then they provide a, an SDK that has an entire build system. So they provide for you the Linux build
system. And it actually has a lot of security stuff built in. It's got some secure boot built in.
Uh, you, you can implement that wrong. So I've, I've seen that sometimes, but it, it's going to be a
Linux system, but then maybe, but that's going to do like all of the AI stuff,
but then maybe there's a, another S like processor that's doing the motor control.
Right. And so that is more likely those motor control circuits are more likely to be a
microcontroller target and microcontrollers are going to more likely have J tag or SWD,
which is arms version of J tag. Uh, whereas the Linux side, you're going to be looking for you art.
Okay. That makes sense. So overall, likely it's going to have for the more complex robotic pieces,
it's going to have a microcomputer core, right? Yup. So we're running Linux, uh, probably this NVIDIA
here. Um, and then we might have microcontrollers throughout the system that are controlling various
pieces of it and kind of calling back up via these, you know, hub here or this, um, uh, you know, area where
you could hit it with the logic analyzer, um, back up to the, to the microcomputer core, right?
Exactly. And those signals are usually, you are like serial signals also. So that, that those,
there's, there's a couple of different protocols. There's, there's, you are, there's I squared C that
we don't need to get into all there's SPI. There's different protocols that use, you know, digital signals
to, you know, community do inter chip communication. So, and you, and you can, uh, identify those via the
logic analyzer when you hook up and you sort of pull off those connections. Exactly. So the most common
logic analyzer out there, uh, Saley makes really good products, highly recommend them. And, uh, it comes
with this software that's called logic or logic two, and it has these analyzers that you can, you can
plug in an analyzer and you can see if it decodes data properly or not. So you kind of test your
hypotheses. Uh, let me just add that to my Christmas list real quickly. Yeah. No joke. Yeah.
Yeah. Actually. Yeah. So I have lots of dumb questions, but, um, one, one specifically is like,
how do you balance not breaking hardware devices that you get shipped? Like, like when you were
talking about opening up this human robot, I'm just like thinking like if Tesla sent me, I don't know,
one of their humanoid robots and it was like a $50,000 device. And you know, you're telling me like,
yeah, just crack it open, you know, start like soldering stuff onto the back of it. I'm just like,
oh my gosh, I'm going to break this thing. How do I know? Like, you know, how do you balance that?
That is a great question. So on a higher value target. So, so to take a step back,
when I'm doing IOT pen testing or, or bug bounty hunting, I always prefer to have more than one
device. Like ideally I would have two to three devices and I would have one device that is like,
okay, this is my destructive testing target. I don't care if I brick it, I'm going to be really rough with
it. And then I'll have like on the other side of the spectrum, I'll have like the clean device that I
like, I open up only if I really have to, to do very safe operations. But on the hardware hacking
spectrum, when you gain experience, this is why I always suggest for people to go, go to Goodwill,
go buy some used routers and like practice on those targets that are like $20, not the $50,000 target.
But after you've had some experience, you know, which operations are risky or pretty safe. Now,
obviously anything you could make a mistake and I could I could do my safe operation on the device
and I could still break it if I'm being if I'm really unlucky that day. But interacting with you
art, that's gonna be pretty safe. Like like doing hot air and pulling a chip off which is kind of the
the other phase is is doing firmware extraction on a device. So kind of my two big hardware hacking
operations. It's debug look for debug interfaces. The other one is do firmware extraction. And anytime
you have to do firmware extraction, especially if you're physically pulling the chip off the device,
you're at risk of messing stuff up. Dude, when you said two to three, I was like, man, this guy's a boss,
you know, like in the one, excuse me, but in the one live, you know, live hacking event that I did
for hardware, they and you were there, Matt. So I think you got the same thing. But like, yeah,
they sent us a link and they said, Hey, you can buy three and we'll reimburse you.
And and they sent us the link to the three to the three pack. So I bought three of the three packs.
And they did they reimbursed me. I was like, Hey, you told me I could buy three of these,
you know, and and and then I did buy three of these, you know, and and so I had nine devices. And
dude, I burnt through like six or seven. Like I was just like frying it with the gun, you know, with the hot
air gun. And so I was like, Yeah, I mean, for me, it's a minimum of five devices, I think.
That's funny. Since we've mentioned is a digital analog or logic analyzer, a physical device.
Yes, yes, it is. It's a physical device. You can buy the knockoffs on Amazon for about $20. I'll get
you guys some links to throw in your show notes. So there's there's a $20 one that'll that'll more or less
get you what you need. You're gonna it like it's gonna have an advertised sampling rate on it. That
is is not true. Like you're never gonna get that rate. But for most of our hardware hacking stuff,
not gonna matter. It'll be fine. And then salee obviously is kind of the the Cadillac of a logic
analyzer and they have a new device out which is really fun like that just just me nerding out but
they have a device that combines a logic analyzer and an oscilloscope. So if you really need an
oscilloscope for any work you're doing. Yeah, it's all in one. For sure. Yeah. I'm using an
oscilloscope all the time. Does a does a flipper come in handy much at all? Oh, so I the flipper is
grown on me. So I would say it's kind of a toy. But I have used it funny enough. I've used it in
hardware assessments. I actually bought it for a pen test. Because I knew I was going to need to do
infrared. It was I can say the general target. It was a TV like a smart TV. And some of these smart
TVs the remotes will have like undocumented commands that you can send over infrared to the
television. And so I needed a way to kind of programmatically interact with that. So I was
writing custom so for that pen test I was like writing custom flipper apps that would that would send
data over infrared. So there it's useful in some cases. There are some limitations to it. And they're
currently developing a new one that's going to be like a full blown Linux system basically. That's
going to have a lot more capabilities. But I would say it's it's kind of a toy is how I usually use it.
Yeah. Go ahead, Justin. You were going to say something?
Yeah. Well, I was just going to I was going to ask before about about something else.
But we can jump into the hardware hacking zero to hero hardware hacking guide. Because I think you had
some thoughts on some questions on exactly how to proceed with that. And I think we've covered
it up to a good point here. We've covered it up to reconnaissance. And so we're looking for debug
interfaces by you art J tag, USB, that sort of thing. And then the other side of that is is
firmware extraction. Before we jump over to firmware extraction. Did you have anything else on on like
the the debug interface side tips and tricks for identifying those or tools we might need to
to be able to identify those and hook up to them?
Um, no, I don't have anything else. I would like to go back if we're going to the zero and hero,
I'd like to jump up to that kind of philosophy first and jump down into that. Because this is
something I get this question a lot. And sometimes you can get stuck into the weeds of the hardware
hacking. And so I like to clarify for people what like the goal usually is of our hardware hacking. So
to start that there, there are such things as hardware vulnerabilities like, like flaws that are baked
into the silicon. These are these are oftentimes unfixable flaws, but like like like the fix is to like,
make a design and fabricate a new chip is usually the fix for a hardware flaw like that. So what I find
is typically not technically a hardware flaw, it's software flaws in hardware devices. And so I say that
because usually all this hardware hacking stuff, my philosophy is a means to an end of hacking on
software. And it's a means to the end of turning what is like a black box assessment because think
about like, you get a device and you can like, maybe it had maybe it has like an ethernet port on it,
you like plug it into your network, you're like, I could run like an map on it, I can start like you
could treat it like a network pen test. And that'd be black box, right? Maybe there's a web app on it. And
you could treat it like a black box web pen test. But the thing that hardware hacking gets us in that
threat model in that scenario is that it turns a black box assessment into a gray box assessment,
it gives us more intelligence on how the device works on the inside. Dude, Frick, that is such a
beautiful point. And it makes it so much more approachable, right from, you know, from from a
software hackers perspective, right? If I'm if I'm working on my web stuff, and I'm thinking, Oh,
you know, hardware stuff, that's like, so like the soldering and the bloody lot, right? You know,
all of that is just a way to get you source code. And once you get source code, you know,
you're like, Ah, this is this is where I live, you know, and then it goes back to those,
those comfortable skills of source code review of web hacking. And of course, there are things like,
you know, Bluetooth, or like, like, you're mentioning all these UDP protocols that, you know,
web hackers in particular, aren't super comfortable with. But at the end of the day, it's just a
different skill set of, of, of software hacking, right? Yeah. And that makes it a lot more
approachable. I really, I really like that clarification. That's, that's great.
Yeah. So then so then, yeah, and then I kind of break down my, my process, again,
into those two categories, there's debug interfaces. And so the debug interfaces, again, on this kind of,
this map of, we're trying to get more information, we're trying to get our hooks into the device,
so we can hack on the software, so we can find a software flaw in the device, the debug interfaces,
they, they get like, if we can get a shell on a Linux device, right? In the context of turning it into a
gray box assessment, we can we can just like, we can view the process, the running processes on the
system, we can, like, look at those processes that have sockets open, right? So then we can start to
connect the dots to say, like, okay, before I was performing this black box assessment, and I saw this
open port, like, maybe there's a web application running on this IoT device, right? Well, and you're
asking, well, where's the code for that, right? If I can run netstat, and I can see, okay, port 80 is
being opened by this process named web, you know, like, like, there's some binary that is listening on
that port. Now I know exactly where to go in the firmware, or on the device. And I can, because, because,
because when you when you look at firmware, you're looking at like, a million files, you're like, what
do I look at first? And so those debug interfaces often tell us exactly where to look on the device.
That's beautiful, man. It's like, it's like, if you have a shell on a server, how much easier would
it be to hack that, you know, like, it's, it's, it's beautiful. And especially when they attack surfaces.
So, um, so rich, like it is on a lot of these IoT devices, right? There's, there's, um, you know,
there's some, something happening over here, over HTTP, there's something happening over here over,
like, there's some weird UDP protocol, or like, you know, there's so there's a lot of, uh, attack
vectors in, uh, in these sort of scenarios, typically, um, Bluetooth stuff, right? All of that's really
fun. So yeah, it feels like there's kind of like three things you're doing by, by hardware probing.
You're like getting access to scope. You didn't have access to before. Like you could test things that you
weren't able to test. You can reduce friction, which I think is what Justin loves to say all the time
around testing things by being able to test them in a more like automatable fashion or in like a more
repeatable fashion. Um, oh man, what was the third one? Yeah. But it sounds like those are like the main
things, right? Is that you're one able to get access to scope. Other people can't or reduce the friction
that it takes to test these tough things to test. Yeah, totally. Yeah. Okay. So, so we've,
we've gone down that route. We, we, we've tried to identify some debug interfaces. How often do you
think there are no debug interfaces or like maybe the, the, um, they burnt these or something, right?
Like I I've heard in the past, like what'll happen is they'll, they'll like, um, you know,
break the fuses or whatever on, on those specific lines. Yeah. Yeah. So there, there can be cases where
the debug interface, I mean, frankly, on most bug bounty targets, cause bug bounty targets tend to be more
secure than the, the, the not bug bounty targets generally. I mean, obviously that's not always the
case. Uh, but especially in the hardware world, cause there's not as many hardware programs as there
are, uh, web programs. So tend to be a little bit more, uh, a hardened device where they take security
seriously. And so, yeah, oftentimes you're going to be left with maybe no debug interfaces or you're going
to be left with like a UART connection that doesn't let you send any data, but you might, you might get
some data out, right? Like maybe you'll get like standard out standard error of like of some programs
running on the system, or maybe you'll get the kernel logs during boot up or, or maybe it'll just be
blank and you won't get anything. So, uh, then the next step is firmware extraction because, uh, with
firmware extraction, we can usually get some of the firmware, hopefully out of the device. And so, uh,
that's where we're going to turn to look at those, those flash chips that are on the device. And
this does become kind of a game of pattern recognition of, uh, okay. It's like, I can now
look at a PCB and I can see a certain shape of a chip and I'm like, that's the flash chip right there.
Obviously, uh, when you're new, when you're new, you're, you're probably going to have to read the
little, uh, serial numbers, little model numbers that are written on the chip, do some Googling,
and you're like, you Google it and you're like, Nope, that's the CPU. You Google it. Nope. Nope.
That's the DRAM. And then you're like, Oh, here, this is like, you know, flash,
like EMS and the MMC flash chip or, or a spy flash chip, something like that.
Hmm. So what are, what are some, uh, you know, I knew EMMC, but I didn't know the second one,
you said spy flash chip.
Yeah. So there's, well, okay. So, so technically that's the protocol that, uh, the chip is speaking.
So those come in a lot of different packages. So in the, in the hardware world,
a package just is, is the name for the physical dimensions of the chip. So you're probably familiar
with EMMC. It's a larger, uh, square to rectangular chip and, uh, they actually come in a lot of
different dimensions. And so sometimes you need like different little, uh, cutouts to, to, to place that
chip into your programmer to read the, read the firmware out. Uh, but there's also, you know,
little eight pin chips that, uh, and, and especially on cheaper devices, you're, you're more likely or,
or cheaper or lower power or, you know, lower budget devices that you're just going to find those,
those kinds of flash chips. And so there's some that are like call the TS, uh, a TSOP 48. I could,
I could rip off all the names then that wouldn't be too helpful for everybody. Uh, but there's,
it's a little, uh, you know, chip with, you know, 48 pins, uh, you know, 24 each side. And so
uh, those are, those are some common ones you'll find, but oftentimes if you're not familiar with
it, the, the, the solution, the easy path is just look at the model number that's written on the chip,
Google all of the things that are written on the chip and you'll, you'll probably figure it out.
And eventually you'll figure it out. Okay. Yeah.
So once you have detached it, how do you then actually like view the firmware?
Exactly. So this is where different, uh, firmware reading tools are going to come in handy.
So the most universal universal programmer that I recommend all the time is called the X GECU,
X G E C U. Uh, that platform is a device that has a lot of different sockets that will fit lots of
different types and shapes of chips into them. And they have profiles for many, many different types
of flash chips that you can read. You can read EMMC flash chips now with the, with the, uh, the, the
better models of this, uh, firmware reader and all, all the way down to the really, uh, low budget
chips. And so, uh, there's a piece of software. The official one runs on windows. There is a open source
project called mini mini pro that tries to give you, uh, some, some open source options to interface with
the reader. It works sometimes. So I've resulted to having a burner laptop that sits over here that
doesn't have access to anything else in my network because it runs this Chinese exe that, uh, that you
probably don't want just like on the rest of your network. So, uh, you're on this software. It
interfaces with the, with the flash reader. You place the flash chip in a socket. There's many
different sockets that you can buy, uh, to fit all the different kinds of chips into the reader.
And then you click a button and it says, here's the, here's a binary file with all the firmware.
Mm-hmm. Yeah. And then what do you do with the binary file in order to like actually make sense of
it? Dude. Okay. Hold on, hold on, hold on, hold on. Before we go down that route, like I just gotta
just give the listener the beauty of that moment. Like guys, you can all understand the moment when
you take this flash chip and you put it in your thing and it reads it successfully guys, like it is
just, oh, it is one of my favorite moments that I've ever had in hacking is that moment when it, when I,
and it was crazy cause it's not even really the hacking, right? It's just like, you know,
just getting it. I feel like I just plugged them, you know, micro USB chip into my computer. But like
the fact that now I'm staring at the, you know, the file system of this thing that I'm trying to hack,
I just feel so much like, like potential, you know, and, and hope for how I'm going to like destroy this
device. Um, so really beautiful there. I did want to jump back before we go into what we do with that
binary. Um, you know, when you are removing these chips, I see in your notes here, you have your gun
set to 800 or to 850 Fahrenheit. I feel like that's freaking hot. Is that not like super hot?
That's probably hotter than most people would recommend, but, uh,
yeah. Is there a reason why you do that? Or I I'm impatient, uh,
well, that makes me feel a little bit better. Cause like, you know, Joel, uh, you know, Joel,
my cohost, um, you know, for the first couple of years was yelling at me one time. Cause I was like,
trying to, it's funny cause we were working together on this event. And for some reason,
he did not have the device. I forget. And maybe he was like a plus one, that event or something like that.
But I was like, Hey man, you know, guide me how to hack this. Right. And, and, and I'm like setting
the air gun. He's like, no, don't put the air gun that high or else you're going to fry the chip.
And I'm like, Oh shit. You know, like, and I'm like, you know, trying to undo it. And, um,
but it was only at like 450 or like 500. And I was like, let me just eat, you know,
he would look the other way and I would like ease it up a little bit. Cause it, it takes a while to,
to burn off the, you know, the solder that holds it, holds it there.
Yeah. Especially with those larger ships, like you were dealing with an EMMC chip.
So the kind of, kind of the most standard package for an EMMC chip is 153 solder balls
that are underneath that chip. It's just a large surface area. Also, depending on the device,
like, you know, underneath of it and, or, or on the size of this chip,
there's oftentimes these massive heat shields, these large metal components that are going to soak
up the heat that you're just, I mean, you're just, you're just blowing heat indiscriminately.
I mean, you're trying to, you're trying to aim it at the chip, but obviously these large metal
surfaces are going to absorb a bunch of that heat. And so on those targets, sometimes I'll go and I'll
try to like rip off all the shields before I do something like that, just because it'll be less heat
for the, uh, to be absorbed elsewhere. Totally. Totally. That makes sense. Okay. So, sorry. Going
back to your question, Joseph, um, we we've extracted the binary. We've, we've got the firmware image. What's
your go-to, uh, strategy from there, Matt? Yeah. So bin walk is, is definitely the, the go-to tool for
extracting firmware. So the urine bin walk dash lowercase E, and that will attempt to just go
through this large binary file, because like you said, you don't get handed a, a, a partition table
out of the firmware file, right? You don't get handed all these individual partitions. I mean,
sometimes you can do it with EMMC, but usually you have to like already know the partition table,
so it doesn't really help you. Uh, so when you get that one large binary file, so let's say it's like
a 16 gig, you know, EMMC chip, you just get a 16 gig file that has all of the file systems, the
partitions crammed into one file. And so what bin walk will do is it will try to signature detect,
you know, Hey, I see an ext for Linux file system here. Let me, let me, let me carve that out and try to
unpack the file system. Now, sometimes bin walk will fail on you. So this goes back to kind of the
debug interfaces. Oftentimes, if you do get a, a boot printout on you art, oftentimes on a Linux system,
it will, uh, in the boot logs of like when the kernel starting up, it will show you like a readout of
the partition table and all of the offsets. So sometimes if bin walk is, is just sometimes it's
like not able to detect, or it's got a really weird file system, uh, in one of those partitions,
you can oftentimes go and get all of the offsets from the, you are print out. And then you can
basically more or less convert that into D D D commands, uh, using D D to, uh, you know, carve out the
exact bytes at the exact offsets for each partitions. And then you can try to use other tools from there
uh, more kind of like standard tools to unpack certain file systems. Check the magic bytes on
those or whatever, you know, and, and make sure you've got your, your stuff aligned properly and then
pull it all out. Exactly. That's cool, man. That's freaking cool. I, I, I've seen those readouts before
and, and, but I never correlated that with, with like, Oh wow. If my, I, my bin walk is having some
issues, then I can, I can use that. So that's, that's a really cool tip. Um, sweet. And then from
there, you all would do things like look for secrets, find routes, see what types of, um, source code you
can get for both the device and any web apps and just like do traditional open source code review at that
point. Right. Yeah. And, and most of the time, so sometimes, uh, you get lucky and you'll get source code on
your IOT device, but most of the time it's going to be binaries. That's why I say we're, we're, we're going
from black box to gray box. It's not completely open because oftentimes, uh, you'll, you'll see it. Like if you see a web
app on an IOT device, most of the time it's going to be written in C and it's going to be a compiled,
uh, server where the web server and web application are like custom and they're like all one. Well,
and so, uh, there's a lot of, uh, so that's where you get into binary reverse engineering with tools
like Ghidra, binary ninja, IDA pro things like that. How, how often are you able to get those binaries
back to something more readable than, you know, like assembly, you know, like, like, like sometimes
there's compiled Python, sometimes there's, you know, some CGI, you know, stuff going on, you know,
what, what, what often do you see what stacks? Yeah. So I think we're in a much better position.
So when I, when I kind of started my career, you know, 10, 10, 15 years ago or whatever, we had
IDA pro, which you had to pay, you have to pay out the nose for it's expensive. Uh, and that was it.
Since then, uh, the NSA open source to Ghidra and so, uh, Ghidra's D compiler is very effective. Uh,
and now we also have binary ninja that is entered to market. So we have, we, we don't have like this
monopoly in the software, uh, binary reverse engineering kind of tool space anymore, which is
really great. It's spurred competition, uh, which is always good for the market. So we've got a lot,
we've got a lot of good tools that will get you back to more or less what the original C looked like.
Again, oftentimes these programs are going to be C, C plus plus. Uh, sometimes you'll find,
you'll find, you'll find some Python, uh, in there. But really like 90% of the time or more,
it's going to be C. Yep. Exactly. Dang it, man. Oh, that hurts. That hurts. Man. I really have
gotten lucky because it's twice now that I have dealt with, um, you know, IOT devices that are not
straight, uh, you know, straight C I, you know, and so my, my experience is, is so like, you know,
uh, flowery, you know, it's like, oh, great. And then I pop it open and just decompile this Python
or like pop this jar into, you know, JADX or whatever. Right. And it's like, okay. Um, but it's
not, it's not normally that way, I guess. No. And, and, and if I had to like give my meta analysis of
that, I would say that bug bounty targets tend to be on some devices that I would say are more or
less like over specced or overbuilt. So they have more powerful CPUs or resources on those systems.
And therefore they can afford to run Python, which is not as efficient as C or C plus plus. So,
but on, on a lot of like low power, low resource devices, you're probably not going to find Python.
Dang, man. Dang, that sucks. Well, I, I, uh, I so enjoyed my, my little stint there in the
Python code review land, but that's not what I can expect from most IOT devices. It doesn't seem.
Unfortunately, no, I, I wish, I wish that was the case. Yeah.
Sweet. And then, so we have, uh, Matt graciously gave us like a list of like six links. There's an
intro playlist by make me hack for getting into hardware hacking. There's a post about UR SPI. And then
there's a bunch of links to Matt's videos about your interaction and firmware extraction that we will
put in the show notes and the hacker notes for everyone. Hmm. Hmm. That should be great. Yeah.
Those are always good reviews. And then did you want to jump from there, Joseph over to yes. I'm not
going to let us, I'm not going to let us hang up today. I'm not going to let us get off here without
talking about this IOT hack bot. So, okay. Yeah. So Matt, we heard that you built an IOT hack bot,
basically a agent that helps you hack. So tell us the full story, you know, well, you know, what is
it? How did you build it? Do you have a video about it? Well, I was shooting some ideas over Terezo
here. And, uh, I was telling him about some, about some stuff I was doing. So it was originally just
using cursor. I have to say I'm a late adopter to all of the LLM stuff. I was maybe in the skeptical camp at
first. Uh, so I'll, I'll admit that I'll admit that here on the pod, but, uh, I've started to see the
value. So I originally started by wanting to build some very specific tools. So where this started,
I was, uh, doing some security research on some IOT cameras, and I wanted to build some
attack tools that were very specifically targeted to these set of cameras. So in the security camera
world, there's a standard called on VIF, which is a standard set of APIs that uses soap and XML and
it's gross. And I hate, I hate soap. And so I'm like, you know what, an LLM could probably code me a
tool in Python that'll make me not have to like, you know, uh, blow my brains out because I'm like
writing all this like XML stuff into my, into my Python tool to do checks. So, uh, so it all, it all
started that way with, with writing this tool. So in on VIF, there's a, there's a set of APIs that are
defined in the standard and some are pre-auth that you can execute without authentication and then
everything else should require authentication. So I wrote this tool to go through every API in the spec
and try to see if I can access it without authentication. So it requires a different,
soap, you know, XML payload for each one, which would just, I mean, that would have just been pure
pain to try to do that. But, um, yeah, but, but, but, uh, the LLM was able to just go, oh yeah,
I'll go read the spec and I'll write a Python tool that will, that will execute that. And I found some
bugs. And so this got me started on this journey of, okay, what if I could, you know, build some kind
of agents or stuff like that. And that's when I reached out to you and you were like, hey, you
should, you should use cloud code. And on the same day, it just so happened that that was like,
it was on the same day that, uh, cloud released their skills. And so that, uh, it's, it's with,
which cloud skills are, um, I mean, it's, I don't know if it's an overhyped feature, but it's really
helped me. And so, uh, cloud skills are basically a markdown file where it doesn't read in the whole
markdown file into the context window, uh, where you can tell it how to use certain tools. So I started
out by, okay, I had these two little tools for testing these IP cameras. And so I was like, all right,
let's create cloud skills for those. And then I could just let cloud code use them and it basically
one shot, you know, this camera and, and was able to find like a bunch of Vons. And then I even posted
a video of how I was able to tell it to like write a payload. Uh, so in the on VIF spec for PTZ cameras,
which are, uh, pan tilt zoom cameras that can actually move physically on their own. Uh,
and I had a camera that supported that I was able to tell Claude to go and, you know, like, like enumerate,
like, like, like, find if there's any volumes. And I'm like, and if there's a Vaughn, I mean,
I knew there was a Vaughn, but if there's a Vaughn, you know, move the camera. And so, uh, it was able to,
you know, find the APIs that didn't have off and then use those APIs to move to physically move the camera.
How crazy is that, man? You're just like, move the camera and then you wait. And all of a sudden it goes
and you're like, Oh my gosh. I mean, that's the closest thing to like in a movie where it's like,
you know, like computer, computer, hack this device and make it move. Like, give me a better view of
the angle. And the computer runs off. And it's like, I'm going to use Matt Brown's skill to go hack this.
And then I'm going to turn the device. Right. It's like, exactly. It's like achieves. Yeah.
It's like Riley from national treasure. Right. You know, the, that was like when I was younger,
that was my like hacker inspiration was like the dude from national treasure that was like, all right,
I'll turn off the security cameras, you know? Um, wow. That's actually Matt Brown's like Tuesday, you
know? Yeah. The reason why I recommended Claude code just for all the listeners is it's just such a
malleable agentic, um, rapper, you know, like, I think that that's, what's so powerful about it.
I think they're building it that way on purpose. You know, like Daniel Measler uses it for his like
personal assistant and he gives like all the context about his projects and his businesses and
a bunch of skills and he used it for that. Right. In this case, Matt Brown basically made a hack bot
out of Claude code. And it's so much easier and better to do that for most people than to build it
from scratch. Right. Cause you're, you're running all of that wrapper logic. Anytime you're going to
build an agentic system, but you can just like borrow the agentic wrapper or the agentic harness from
Claude code, and then just give it the ability to do the things you want to do. And for a hundred dollars a
month, you basically have like written your own custom agent, right. That's actually like really
good. And we'll always improve as they improve their system prompts, as they improve their models,
as they improve the tool calling. And so anyways, that's why I recommended that to Matt. And I think,
you know, for 99% of use cases, that's the best thing you can do. Um, obviously with like with Kaido,
Justin and I incorporated shift deeply into it because it needs to have access to all of the different
things that Kaido can do. And so, you know, I think that's the next step for a lot of things, but
if you have a desire or a goal to achieve with some sort of AI agent, I think the first thing that most
people should do is POC it by like, you know, just giving skills to Claude code.
Yeah. Yeah. And that was such a good suggestion. Cause I think I linked to you one of the open source
agent, you know, you know, pen testing, uh, or security testing agent systems. I'm like, oh yeah,
I'm thinking about doing this. And you're like, eh, you should just use Claude code. And I'm like,
that was a, that was a, that was a good move. I would have gone way too far down the rabbit hole that did
not need to go, uh, did not need to be explored at that time. So yeah, it's, it's, it's amazing,
man. I actually, instead of using Claude code, I'm actually using Gemini CLI and, and after hearing
more about Claude code, I'm not sure that that's 100% the best, you know, decision, but I am sort of
living in that ecosystem a bit right now. So, um, I think I'm going to stick with it for the time being.
I have seen in shift that Claude is way better at tool calling, uh, you know, so that, that is
definitely goes to Claude. Um, but I, I had a similar situation where, um, you know, I kind of give
it a, uh, you know, obscure protocol that, that is just horrible to write. And I say like, look,
just map this to like a JSON file for me, please. And then write, you know, write a Python file to map it
back to, to whatever, like garbage, you know, this is, and it did it. And it totally changed the game
for hacking that target. Cause you just reduce so much friction in creating your payloads and, and, uh,
you know, how much more thorough can you be when you're not like spending an hour on one, you know,
API endpoint crafting the, you know, XML you need, right. Versus like, you know, you might get two
through two or three of those before you're like, ah, they probably all have auth, you know, versus like,
if you, if you can just spit them out, you're like, ah, well, I'll just test all of them really quick.
And then you find that, you know, second to last one that is like, doesn't have auth and gives you a shell.
So yeah, it's unlocking new scope and then reducing friction. Those same two things, right?
Yeah, exactly. And, and, and, and I love the ability of Claude. Yeah. The reversing binary, like, like, like,
binary protocols or some undocumented protocol. So that was the other cool video
I did on this same video camera. So, uh, did one, you know, did one where we found all of the,
the, the, the, the phones in the protocol that was documented that followed this specifications,
this open specification. There was also this UDP port, uh, that had this completely undocumented
protocol. And that led me to develop these other skills. And one of them was the ability to
interact with my hardware hacking tools. So my UR interface that I had hooked up to this camera that in
this case was able to give me a root shell. I wrote a Claude skill for Pico com, which is just one of the
Linux utilities. That's a terminal emulator that allows you to interface with the device. So now I can give
Claude code a shell on an IOT device and it can run commands to enumerate the system just like I would do,
uh, in a pen test. And this was really important for in the, in this video for reversing a binary
protocol because, helpfully, the main binary, uh, that, that was running this binary protocol would send
logs to standard out that would appear on the console. And so it was able to, you know, craft a script,
run, uh, an exploit over the network so that the device is connected over the network. It can talk
to it over the network and it had a shell on the device. And so it could, it could get that feedback
because as a security researcher, that's the flow. I w that's what I would do, right?
Totally. Is I would craft PO, POC scripts. I would send a payload, uh, to a service. And then I would
try to get any kind of intelligence on the device. Like, is there, is there something going to a log
file that I can see an error message, uh, that will help me fix my, my POC, my, my exploit.
Yeah. So yeah, I think, I think that this is very similar to, I think this is just an overarching
principle for LLMs. Like a lot of people, they just want them to work because you see, you know,
the magic of, of cursor or whatever. Right. But I think a lot of stuff that's a little bit more
nuanced like this, and I'm finding this out with shift and you, you've seen this with your own,
you know, Claude hack bot is making sure that they have the right tools and the right information.
Right. Because our brains sort of fill in the details. I'll give an example from this. Like I,
because by the time this, um, this pod airs, my Nihama Khan talk will already have run. But, um,
one of the things I'm talking about in that is how, uh, like shift agents, which is essentially
the web version of this, right. With inside of Kaido, they get so much more effective when you give
them things like the session token in an environment variable, right. That it can, they can, it can sub in
very easily, um, or additional pieces of context surrounding that. Right. So if you, if you,
and a lot of times, you know, as humans, if we look at the session token, we can say, okay,
that one starts with 983 or whatever, that's this user. Well, the other one's got to be the other
user then. Right. But if you can, you know, define this for the LLM, spell it out a little bit easier,
give them tools to make this stuff a lot, a lot quicker. The performance just like goes through
the roof. So building that, that tool, right. For you to get access to, to standard, um, standard out
and, and, or standard error here and like watch these logs. I mean, that's, that's gotta be the game
changing move, uh, for the, for this whole thing. And then it was able to completely based off of
those logs and with the Python script, it would just reverse it. And they gave you something that
can speak that protocol. Exactly. Yeah. And the one other piece that is a future improvement. So
the other piece I was giving it also was decompiled source code that I had, I had copied and pasted out of
my out of binary ninja. So the next piece for me is to do MCP to those tools. Yeah. So, uh, I'm
exploring different options. Ghidra obviously has, uh, you know, Ghidra MCP. Uh, there, there's some
limitations of that. I think you, you have to like manually open the binary. You can't have it like
programmatically in a binary. At least that's my understanding at this point. So yeah, I'm looking at
some different options for that. I know that, I know that Caleb Gross, um, an operator has done
some really interesting research on reverse engineering and then using LLMs to like identify,
uh, you know, specific pieces of the code that like he was, he did it specifically with patch diffs,
right? So you can say, okay, Hey, you know, here's the CV, here's the description. Here is a patch diff,
you know, in, you know, the, of the binaries, right? What function is the one that fixes the patch
and where the vulnerability was, you know, and then he's got it nailed down to like the top, like
4% of all the functions that can be like, okay, this is the one, you know, that are, that is related
to this. Um, so I think, you know, being able to use something like that, I know he's got a tool called
sift, um, that can help you really sort of narrow down. Okay. Well, these are the pieces of
functionality that we're really interested in for, uh, the specific piece of functionality.
Um, and then pass that to the AI. It seems to get substantially better results.
That's awesome. I need, yeah, I need to check that out. Yeah. Well, I'll, uh, I'll hook you up
with him after this, after this pod. Um, yeah, Joseph, I think we've hit a lot of the items here on
our list. Did you have, uh, have something else here? No, I'm yeah. All of my, uh, questions have
been asked. All of my answers have been found. Um, no, I'm excited to, uh, to mess with this stuff
more. I think that honestly, I'm going to have some sort of like hardware arc in 2026. Uh, that'll,
that'll be the goal. Dude, you and me together, man. I was thinking, I was talking to Matt. We'll see.
We'll see. Maybe, maybe we'll put this in the pot or not, but it would be really awesome to do a,
um, upon to own team, you know, uh, together, you know, if next time they, they release like their,
their target list, just pick one and then, you know, have, have Matt do, do some of the hardware
stuff, have us go, you know, find out the vulnerabilities in the, in the software stack.
Once we've got access to source code or whatever, um, or, you know, gray box, right. Decompiled
binaries as it always ends up. Um, I think that could be a blast. Yeah. Let me select.
Yeah. All right, Matt. Well, thank you so much for coming on the pod, man. It has been very
insightful as always. And, uh, yeah, definitely going to do some hardware hacking with you this
upcoming year. If we can tweak, can't wait seated. That's the pot. And that's a wrap on this episode
of critical thinking. Thanks so much for watching to the end y'all. If you want more critical thinking
content, uh, or if you want to support the show, head over to ctbb.show/discord. You can hop in the
community. There's lots of great high level hacking discussion happening there on top of the master
classes, hack alongs, exclusive content, and a full-time hunters guild. If you're a full-time
hunter, it's a great time. Trust me. All right. I'll see you there.